Welcome to the third in this
series of age word problems.
And I just wanted to start
off where I left off
in the second one.
I got myself confused.
You guys make me very nervous
while you just sit there
listening and I have
to perform for you.
But, it turns out we did get
the right answer, if you say
Arman is 153 and Tarush is 765,
then 85 years ago Arman would
have been 68 and Tarush
would have been 680.
And notice that's 10 times.
So it worked out.
So we're ready to tackle
another problem.
One more problem.
Let's see.
This problem says, Zack is
4 times as old as Salman.
What a coincidence.
Salman really shows up
in a lot of problems.
So Zack is 4 times
as old as Salman.
Zack is also 3 years
older then Salman.
How old is Zack?
Well, actually this one
actually seems fairly
straightforward.
We're not dealing with the
present and the future.
We're just dealing
with the present.
So let's see if we
can figure this out.
So we're trying to figure
out how old is Zack.
Let's say, z for Zack.
z equals Zack.
It says Zack is 4 times
as old as Salman.
So, Salman, if Zack is
z, this first sentence,
let me circle it.
Zack is 4 times as
old as Salman.
So, if Zack is 4 times as old
as Salman, that means that Sal
is equal to Zack divided by 4,
But then it also says here that
Zack is also 3 years
older than Salman.
Well, if Zack is also 3
years older than Salman, so
that means that also Sal
would be Zack minus 3.
The first sentence says Zack
is 4 times as old as Salman.
So that means if you take
Zack's age and divide it
by 4, you get Sal's age.
The second sentence says
Zack is also 3 years
older than Salman.
So that means if you take
Zack's age and you subtract
3 from it, you get
Sal's age again.
Well, we have our
equation set up.
And, actually, instead of
writing Zack, I should
have just written z.
But the equation is
all set up for us.
We get z over 4 is
equal to z minus 3.
We can multiply both sides of
this equation times 4 and we'll
get z is equal to 4z, remember
to distribute, minus 12.
And then, we'll skip
a couple of steps.
And I get 3z is equal to 12.
And I get Zack is
equal to 4 years old.
Let's see if that makes sense.
If Zack is 4 years old, then
this first sentence says Zack
is 4 times as old as Salman.
So that means Sal
is 1 year old.
It also says Zack is 3
years older than Salman.
Well, that's consistent.
4 is 3 more than 1.
So we were right.
Zack is exactly four years old.
Hope that helps.
Have fun.
I think you're ready.
You've now seen, at
least, every type of
the age word problems.
If you're still a little
confused, you might just want
to re-watch the videos and
maybe pause it right after I
give you the problem, and see
if you can solve it yourself.
And remember, you had a lot of
practice problems that you
can do on the actual
modules themselves.
Have fun.